I'm pleased to say that Miss Jason is
with us to talk a little bit more about
this and of course it is Brighton Pride
it is yes so we're all very excited I
was going to say it must be very excited
yes we are first time what about that
documentary please the documentary it's
absolutely beautiful it's a story about
um a man who when he first started to
work in drag it was illegal to be gay
Society has changed it's kept up with
all those changes it's from a generation
that finds sometimes find change a
difficult thing to accept is a man who's
gone through life has lost his partner
his partner died of HIV but it was
through
um a bad blood transfusion so he's had
to live and experience the Prejudice
that comes with losing someone with HIV
um is a man who's coming to terms with
getting older so he can't physically do
the things that he wants so you can see
him there it's lovely so this man has
faced so many changes in his personal
life in society T and he faces every
challenge of every day with such Gusto
is a real inspiration I mean it's just
incredible to think that the way that he
would have seen the way that the society
yes he's lived through with that history
you know and the way it's affected him
absolutely well yes his life is very
different and also the other thing is
he's 89 now so is living with all the
challenges that come with being an 89
year old man you know an 89 year old
person rather but he's still working he
will be upright and pride and the the
the story the film is beautiful it's
really there are moments in it that you
want to cry and then there are moments
in it that you just want to laugh out
loud and I think the underlying message
of it is friendship and laughter get you
through anything and that's certainly
how I live my life inspired by
absolutely David I know it's K Burley
now not David I'm sure she's a bad
abundant laughs as well she's she
certainly is good areas I mean it's as I
said it's just it's such a change in the
culture now and you talked about how it
began uh for for David right when it was
illegal yeah okay and how things have
changed obviously now there has been a
moment in the in the past year or so
where talked about sexuality about
gender have come back in I mean how is
that affecting people who've seen
everything change because it feels to me
like in some of the discourse it it has
got a little bit worse in some in some
respects I think it has
um there's still a lot of prejudices
about you know that and the worst thing
is we hear a lot of rhetoric about
equality and and I think that people
with everyone all around the world but
certainly people in my community are now
a little bit sick to death of lip
service what we need is someone that's
going to follow through and actually
deliver you know I feel totally
disenfranchised by the representation
that we have in this country and and I'm
sick to death of all politicians using
um equal rights and equality trans
rights as as a political football and a
banner to wave as opposed to actually
doing something I wanted to ask you
about that I mean it's such a sensitive
subject I don't want to like delve into
no calls yeah
but it's it's the thing that people will
be interested in talking about I mean
you don't feel like you're getting any
of the support from any of the political
parties absolutely for your community at
all and what would you like to hear
being said what we need is is someone
that's going to represent us positively
and someone that's not just going to
talk about it I mean what's that look
like what it looks like is action on the
street it looks like what it's going to
look like is people not being afraid to
live their lives the way they were born
to be and not being afraid to live the
lives the way they want to live them you
know equality isn't a privilege it's a
right everybody's as long as what you do
in your life is open honest fair legal
and you don't harm anyone else you've
got as much right to live your life the
way you want to as anybody else and it's
about time that changes and how that
feeds into this film is David from his
Generation
Um if he was going to work say a bar
called the two brothers in Clapham he
wouldn't if he was lost he wouldn't ask
anyone the way to the two Brewers
because they would know it's a gay bar
but what he would say is
um can you tell me where Clapham High
Street is and you know Prejudice does
exist it's still there I mean what do
you think about generational thing I
mean people of my generation and younger
do you think they're more accepting of
differences I think so I think
um and do you think I mean that's
obviously that's gonna be a positive
thing
and it's also I mean I'm I'm about what
my 54. so sometimes I find it difficult
to keep up with what's going on and I
never sometimes don't get the right
terminology and sometimes get myself
into trouble I don't mean to
um but you're in the community and you
find it difficult absolutely the trouble
I get I mean I'm an old bird but I was
trying to listen to what the young
people are saying because it's young
people that come along and support us
and the young people are our future
they're taking our community and indeed
our our genre of entertainment on that's
the next step so we've all got to be in
tune but young people there's a there is
a change within Society but the
parliamentarians need to keep up with
that change the change that's happening
it's it's us we're doing it we need
proper leadership and and we need
someone that's really going to engage
with our community we're just funny
let's talk a little about that we've got
the debate coming have you heard
anything from these two we're standing
to learn its prime minister what would
you want to hear and if you could speak
to them what would you say to either I
want to know what their stance is going
to be on equal rights and I just
actually want to know if they're going
to be honest that's the other thing I
mean we just need a leader in this
country that's going to be honest with
us and tell us the truth you know we
can't rely upon anyone there's no
Statesman left in British politics any
longer on either side no no and I look
at what happens in the Commons now I'm
not a politician I'm an Entertainer I'm
supposed to spread the sunshine not
misery but um I look at the commons and
and I think who is there who is there
that we can actually buy into we all we
need is someone solid and honest
personality politics is what's got us in
to this trouble in the first place we
want someone bog standard that's going
to say right folks this is a problem
there's this amount of money you need to
spend this much money absolutely a bit
of housekeeping because Jason I'm going
to stop it there look have a great pride
really love your swatching this morning
thank you so much I've been talking up
about amazing the film no we do but we
will and it's on our website so be able
to pick it up you very much cheers